for the live-action version of a lad now
the new trailer dropped today and it's
got big Willie's Genie size seal of
approval I stand by my wishes three I'm
kidding rush this
[Music]
we'll sings raps it even had muscles
added via special effects to play the
larger-than-life genie but he doesn't
spend the entire film covered in blue
makeup hey can you make me a prince
there is a lot of gray area in make me a
prince I could just thank you friends
oh no that was terrified doing the genie
you know after Robin Williams but you
know I found a lane that you know
Paisley you age but it's my own thing
people are gonna love it sometime will
brings heart and swagger to the role but
can the 50 year old star do stand-up
comedy it's on his bucket list
and et has your exclusive first look at
tomorrow's Facebook watch episode jay
Nixon her show the rare table talks and
you'll see now now you can enjoy it
because she's not telling all your
business okay whatever you want to walk
out of there right he's so talented he
had figured out a lot of things but not
stand up Oh
[Music]